♪ ♪ ♪
- Une montagne de poubelles.s st
sur plus de 50 hectares
Nous sommes à Dandora,
le plus gros dépotoir d'Afrique
de l'Est. Un piège toxique,
où s'affairent pourtant
des centaine
à la recherche de matières
recyclables. Dnenenenes
comme Jeremiah Ngugi,
14 ans à peineétététététététété.
Un travail f
un salaire de misère.
5 cents le killalalalastique;
20 kilos pour un dollar.
Benjamin Gayo aussi
passe beaucoup de temps
dans la décharge de Dandora.
à la rencontre des jeunes
pour tenter de les aider.
Il repère William, 10 ans
seulement, qui en est
à sa première journée
Difficile pour Benjamin
de rester insensible
au sort de ces gamins.
Car il s'identifie à eux.
enfant de la décharge.
Il connaît les dangers
auxquels ils sont exposés.
Sans compter le risque
de se couper sur des éclats
de verre ou de marcheru u u u u.
D'autres périls sont moins
visibles, plus insidieux,
mais ils laissent des traces
Benjamin les connaît bien;
il les a lui-même vécus.
Chaque enfant rencontré es l l .
Un long processus qui commen
au centre de jour situé
juste à côté du dépotoir.isisiss
librement. Ils peuvent
s'y divertir, se reposer.
Ils peuvent surtout parler
de leurs soucis sans être jugés
et obtenir de l'aide pour
leur dépendance à la drogue.
♪ ♪ ♪
L'objectif est de prendre
swswswswahili)
Leur montrer qu'une autre vie
est possiblslslsls s'en donnent
les moyens.
La séance de motivation
est la spécialité
du père Maurizio Binaghi,
de passer à l'étape suivante :
une cure de désintoxication et
une formation professionnelle.
Tous ces jeunes ont déjà fait
Tous ces jeunes ont
le saut. Ils ont déjà quitté
le ghetto, renon l l l la drogue
et entrepris d'apprendre
un métier.
Plomberie, mécanique,
électricité,seseseserie
ou maçonnerie : une formation
express d'
passeport vers une nouvelle vien
pour devenir électricien,
Brian Mutunga réalise
les considère un peu comme
ses enfants. Ils sont
sa plus grande fierté.
dans le droit chemin.
En trois ans, le centre
a
de jeunes.
♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪
Une goutte d'eau face à
du travail des enfants au Kenyan
les statistiques officielles,
Et le problème de la pauvreté,
lui, reste entier. 18 millions
de personnes ici, vivent avec
Mais peu importe pour Benjamin;
chaque enfant rescapé est
à ses yeux une revanche